l'empereur et le chef de l'état japonais
un peu l'équivalent de la reine
d'angleterre
la tradition japonaise veut que le
premier empereur et pris ses fonctions
en lan 660 avant jésus-christ l'empereur
du japon qui règne sur le trône du
chrysanthème a longtemps été une figure
mythique une divinité que ces sujets
devaient révéré mais son rôle est
uniquement symbolique depuis 1947 c'est
à dire depuis l'adoption de la
constitution japonaise dans la foulée de
la deuxième guerre mondiale les
américains avait jonglé avec l'idée
d'abolir la monarchie après la
capitulation en raison du rôle
controversé de l'empereur hirohito
pendant la guerre mais ils ont plutôt
décidé de réduire ses pouvoirs
l'empereur akihito régnait depuis 1989
il a annoncé son départ en 2016 geste
inusité qui a forcé le gouvernement à
adopter une loi spéciale
son fils le prince naruhito devient donc
le 126e empereur du japon
le dernier héritier d'une lignée
millénaire l'air de l'empereur naruhito
s'appellera rewa qui évoque une
civilisation où règnent l'harmonie cette
transition alimente toute une industrie
des imprimeurs ont notamment lancé des
calendriers pour marquer le début de
cette nouvelle ère le 1er mai
[Musique]
à